squeeze aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour
la suite d'alliés de la nation il
fallait qu'on retrouve samuel ce qui
finalement l'amour d'une vie comment je
monte
oui allez certains de qui dit kolon
voilà y'a pas là plein de balles de
trucs parce que finalement à force de
péter de l'android en masse dans
l'épisode d'abord on a plus ou plus rien
quoi qu'est ce qui lui était arrivé cet
homme s'est mis un magazine dans la
bouche mais c'est pas comme ça qu'on lit
monsieur vous est décédé maintenant bien
joué oh là là mais tous deux décédés une
amanda qui se baladait dans le vaisseau
weis au vaisseau 1 1 dans droutsas et
fils peuvent compter pour les enfants
est ce que je faisais du foot us et
voilà allez à bientôt comment estas elle
s'entraîne pour la prochaine saison d'un
tir vif avec des escrimeurs comme ça
sans déconner les gars allez monte
lamanda [ __ ] tu aies gagné une
première saison intervilles de des
biceps
elle est lourde qu elle fait sur lampard
de musset d'un même si un complexe
d'être aussi musclée à ce point où que
j'aille tout le monde est décédé vers
des hommes décédés un mètre plus loin on
est les vivants il fait genre pas deux
fois
faut bien que je le but mais avec quoi
je suis sûr qu'il est vivant il ya
quelqu'un alors dit nous la vérité
bon il est mort oh ben voilà justin mais
j'hallucine quoi le mec juge lui colle
mettrait sur son torse 18 fois de tuer
il fait rien à les voilà à des scènes du
coup maintenant avoir ramassé ce qui
avait sur lui il avait rien sur lui et
lui qu'est ce qu'il fait il un blocage
un bon un blocage au niveau des
vertèbres ça je connais j'ai très mal
dormi mais il est en train de
s'accoupler ressort lui c'est le seul
que servier dont tu encore des cd
non mais c'est une blague c'est ça ou
pas le l'android je vais faire comme moi
ville within de la chaîne allumettes et
qui brûle tous voila c'est bon on a
accès à cette [ __ ] porte
qu'est-ce qui se fixe à ces menaces dans
ce cas je vais trouver un moyen de
parler au [ __ ] ça me laisse je n'ai
pas tout ça non
non oui oui ça me laisse mon amour tu
vas bien non non non non non non naby
épaté tous pectoraux
oui voilà encore au samu et un ça me
scie et vénèrent les gars n'ont ils
s'envoient samuel mon amoureuse arrive
au début du jeu j'ai dit que je l'aimais
pas mais maintenant franchement je les
adore quoi je sais pas d'un coup j'ai eu
une révélation
il faut apprendre à aimer quelqu'un
voilà ça s'apprend olalalala non mais il
faut flipper sans déconner voilà je vous
sers quoi les android font semblant de
décéder bas du carburant voilée du câble
y aura à boire c'est très bon
hop là le petit bouton cash et 10 dons
pour ouvrir la porte c'est scandaleux ça
et là il y en a qui va se réveiller on
va courir va l'esquivé regarder on va
faire un chat voilà est maintenant au
coût c'est bon on est passé ohlala on
s'était d'armurerie le mec est en émoi
sanaa dix cartouches mon gars qu'est ce
qui se passe déjà ça veut dire qu'il va
y avoir de l'ennemi en masse casse
l'apport au le conte la donne à quoi ces
bons à rien des déviations du gasoil à
aller via tu vas brûler mon gars non
mais les gars regardez regardez tout ce
qu'il ya là sérieusement j'appelle les
gars il ya peut-être des films et l'ice
les filles regarder toutes les munitions
qui a su me fait pas peur bien vase il
ya du feu emmerdes
or plus il faut une carte d'accès qui
doit être sur l'un d'eux elle vient il a
dû aller ils vont tous points de feu
voilà barbecue de synthétique
sauf que ça leur fait rien c'est parfait
olalalala immense aire eux
s'il vous plais calmez-vous mec tu es
enfant tu me regardes pas celle au don
lewis je le batte capello un nom à by
which is la question et lequel avait la
carte d'accès lui
voilà ça me wii u alors ça peut être ça
mais c'était dans cette salle tout à
l'heure non mais tu vas te taire toi ta
gueule j'arrive ça me laisse pas
d'électricité bah ouais ben voyons donc
je dois descendre et/ou me taper à pied
ça allait on descend devait avoir une
petite échelle à
oh ok non on part en escalade
franchement sur ce survivant tranquillou
et cassel filaire et de votre canapé
devant attention à la marche
là je considérais que cette victoire
samuel si je peux l'imaginer seydoux
cheveux olala aux battues la regarder le
premier
t'as pas le temps de lecture brûle c'est
vrai que c'est leur affaire va tenter un
truc pour la première fois les gens ça
la grille est donc non ça l'immobilisme
pendant un certain temps c'est tout je
peux me cacher là dessous oh non il m'a
vu il met des coups de pied mes mecs
mais par toi vieux coup aléatoire aïe ça
me sauve moi il est là non non ça mais
si tu fais quoi je parle et et non je
comptais tellement surtout à samuel cela
n'en fait pas ça à baulon réfection avec
des plongées qui sait la création n'est
plus à nouveau la pression et notre
sécurité
oui commandes affiche peinture de toutes
les opérations de confinement de danger
oui enfin que mabri alors sécurisé on a
peut être un progrès cette commune et
non aux non abonnés oui d'accord
oui c'est je vais me dit où c'est
d'accord je m'en occupe
hop là et maintenant je suis un bleu
vêtue la wii je le vois je te le fais
mon amour c'est un peu comme si je
faisais des coûts est finalement souffre
lui je le débranche up a les boules leur
étonnant de réfléchir à nos sols il
devrait avoir avec vous activez
attendant un côté on a une chance sur
deux c'est celui-là géval android comme
ça le cou cassé par terre c'est celui là
le dernier dis moi que tu es en vie ça
me le dis moi que tu es en vie c'est moi
qui ai envie de moi étaient en vie aux
idées moi était en vie il a envie ou pas
c'est bon il a envie oui j'espère juste
élu a pas retourné le cerveau et qui est
pas devenu méchant
samuel si vous êtes en train de mourir
non non au menu la mettais doutes et aux
utiliser les 30 y prier dans le noyau
d'apollo à mon avis il faut redescendre
on est donc revenu est de se mettre en
arrière pour prendre le transit privé
d'apollo on utilise carrément le transit
privé d'apollo vous rendez vous compte
c'est plus les simples transports en
commun qu'on utilisait avant là c'est
comme si on appelait un taxi finalement
un chauffeur privé vers le noyau
d'apollo papa papa c'est parti moi
j'avoue j'aurais bien aimé refaire une
petite bombe même vu comment il est
efficace et merde donc deux trucs
oh non c'est une blague mais c'est une
blague mais non mais non non non non non
mais non c'était crescendo c'était de
pire en pire le revolver puis finit par
l'ours place à dieu je vous aimais
jusque tout on est comme un verre mais
j'hallucine
c'est scandaleux donc en fait là on doit
passer par un conduit pour en gros
débrouiller la porte mais avant
d'accéder par ce conduit
il faut couper l'alimentation du conduit
sinon on meurt cram et voilà que
d'accepter à les activent l'électricité
la convives
ricardo c'est bon c'est coupé regardez
moi ça c'est un [ __ ] d'android
électriciens ou alors informaticiens je
dirais même ou réparateur l'informatique
on s'en fout de son buteur de métier ce
qu'on veut c'est le voir décédé voilà
allez on y va
c'est parti j'ai encore l'option de dans
une époque fort boyard il faut que je me
dépêche avant que le juge revienne et
que la ventilation reviennent aussi ça
va être tendu très tendu un mandat bonne
chance merci
d'accord ok ça marche nickel eye sai on
y trouvait la salle de contrôle d'apollo
pour les humains c'est quoi ça masques à
gaz bien assez pour les zones à risque
tendu là j'ai juste mon petit au hockey
[ __ ] c'est un masque à gaz
j'étais vraiment cru qu'elle se fait à
coups de poing elle même voilà tiré là
bas j'ai raté qui on y va oh mais non je
suis ici parce que je le veux je suis
une femme libre libre libre et brûlé
maintenant salut tétouan tient aux
mecquois mais guzet c'est une blague
menacé mon avis je verrai péronier je
vais les attirer la banane là-bas le
blanc rouge nous sommes les gens me
hania faut que j'allais manche l'un
d'eux oui métis à ce plaisir sur le
terminal du doom
il est où la norme en saas ou oui oh
[ __ ] mais c'est ça qu'il faut faire en
fait qu'on voit les android il faut les
hopla contournement mais voilà le temps
que j'ai bon au nom la sécurité compact
réduire les capacités de sécurité
d'apollo je veux bien qu'est ce que
c'est que ce aubin voilà à quoi servez
ce [ __ ] de boutons voilà ça c'est fait
offre quand même allé un peu vite
consulter apollo mais je le confesse qui
bon pourquoi cette grande à la tremblote
labo à la corsa se met carrément à
vibrer waouh ça va se lever [ __ ] c'est
balèze rendez compte que ça c'est le
plus gros serveurs du vaisseau et je
rentre dans le luron ça va totalement
pas marcher vous allez voir whaou
carrément alors est-ce que ça a marché
oh
elle va redémarrer le système peut être
désengagé les androïdes négatif au nom
qu'est ce qui lie weyland yutani qui est
cet homme
ces établissements à partir de l'état
des commandes d'achats reçu le 21
novembre 2 837 jours après deux jours
après notre départ c'est une blague
qu'est ce que l'ordre social de 139
priorité numéro un pour tous les
spécimens maintenir la station en
quarantaine de refuser les
communications au hockey donc en fait
ils veulent vraiment garder le à les
[ __ ] en fait ils veulent garder la
lienne à sur 7 les [ __ ]
[ __ ] ça foire et quoi en maintenant
enquêter dans le réacteur centrale et
bas sans aucun problème je m'en vais le
mec a racheté sébastopol deux jours
après notre départ et il a ordonné qu'on
fasse en sorte que ce [ __ ] d'alien
survivent méthyle grève qui viennent sur
ce vaisseau on va voir ce qu'il en pense
de la lienne alors enquêté dans le
réacteur centrale bien sûr que je vais à
enquêter en [ __ ] ce look c'est la base
aliens qui tombe des conduits un peu
d'eau ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu
quand même hein on peut le dire on le
voit chez rien aux hommes je te pique au
passage au nom mais c'est vraiment
content et un jeune landes compte qu'on
a toujours plus nos armes oh oui là-bas
fumigènes je disparais aie aie aie aie
ça va pas marcher tout seul ça va pas
marcher
à moins que amon tap ah bah il est là
regardez le au revoir
android alors ce qu'on va faire ce qu'on
raconte aux attentes et du kram et le
pantalon opj de brühl ice est barrée on
sait que pratt choc à plus tard sa fin
de cet épisode à l'isolation je sens que
la fin est proche très proche
je dois qu'à besoin de vous a plu et
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
comme d'habitude j'espère que dans le
prochain épisode
on va pouvoir finalement récupéré nos
habits nos armes pour ce don de sa vie
dans une nouvelle vidéo merci d'avoir
regardé devant tout le monde pis
et